well I thought I'd show you a card trick
that I like to call the little fibs
trick so what we do is we take a deck of
cards and we shuffle a few times to make
sure they're good and make stuff I
usually do this with two people but we
can just do with one person you can
actually do it with three or four people
if you like and then what I do is I have
I have a couple of people pick a couple
of cards maybe I'll take off the top I
don't know four or five that looks like
five I mix them up thoroughly and you
tell me when to start mixing okay stop
okay and then I have two people pick
cards okay so I'll represent both people
here okay so pick pick any cards you
wish okay now what you have to do is
look at the cards and remember them very
important certain value and then the
cards have values in eighth counts as
one two or three up to ten is obvious
Jack queen king is the usual convention
of eleven twelve and thirteen so I want
you to add the two values of the numbers
the cards that you have but don't tell
me that yet so if you got a three and a
king that would be sixty and if you got
a queen two queens would be twenty four
and so on so remember the suit and the
value okay so now I have you put them
back in the package so put one back
maybe there and I'll cover them up cover
it up and put the other one back there
and I cover it up now a magician would
be able to find those cards and put them
up very quickly would probably already
have it in his or her pocket or perhaps
in your pocket but I'm a mathematician
so I'm gonna do it illegitimate honestly
I'm gonna shuffle the cards again and
make sure they're good and mixed up and
ask you now what the two numbers added
up to the value total of the two cars
you selected what was that place they
added up to 21 21 okay so it could be a
jack and a ten it could be a queen than
a nine that could have been to ten and a
half's there are many other
possibilities and then there's the
irrational numbers we didn't even get to
those I couldn't have noticing that you
weren't wearing gloves so in fact you
left your fingerprints on the card so I
think from that point of view I might be
able to find them let's see if I can do
this No
looking for the fingerprints think I
have it so let's shuffle them one more
time to make sure that they're really
lost and then I'm just going to produce
two cards and ask you what your cards
were maybe the King of Hearts in the Age
of clubs what is it that King of Hearts
and that of clubs that was that was
those it was them you got it you got it
good I'm sure for those cards again we
could do this again but it's like
telling a good a good joke the punchline
isn't so funny the second time around so
you really don't want to perform this
exact trick for the same audience the
second time but let me demonstrate
what's actually going on here but this
time I'm going to shuffle them in such a
way that you can see a little more
carefully what I'm really up to I'm deep
chuffing a lot of the cards but if you
look closely you'll see that I'm not
shuffling quite a large chunk at the top
so actually maybe eight or nine cards at
the top
we're not shuffle them I can do this
several times and if I do it fast it
looks like an honest shuffle especially
if I don't give you the benefit of the
angle that's the way I showed it earlier
but if you see the angle and I do it
slower you can see that in fact I have
control over some of the cards the top
five or six cards actually the top six
cards is what's particularly important
so let me take them off so I've done a
false shuffle here and given the
illusion of free choice but actually
you're dooms to pick two cards from
particular cards and I'm going to show
you what they are
and see if you recognize them they're
kind of famous numbers so one what might
come after one we're probably two what
do you think comes after two most people
would go for three what comes after
three well obviously four but wait a
minute
if I was to use these cards and you
selected those two you attorney the
total was five but if somebody else
selected these other two they would also
get a total of five and that would be
ambiguous the whole point of this trick
is that from the total I do know what
the cards are even though I pretend I
don't because you're picking from a
control subset of the deck so we
probably shouldn't use the four so in
fact we might want to jump to five now
we don't have the problem you had before
now what comes after five most people
would say six but six isn't such a good
idea
because six plus one is seven and so is
five plus two so maybe we should jump to
seven but 7 plus 1 is 8 and so is five
plus three so we can't use seven but
turns out that eight were
now actually we can push this a little
further we can go one two three five
eight and another card if we do a 9 9 m1
is 10 so it's 2 and H turns out we can't
use 10 we can't use a jack or a queen
either for similar reasons guess what
you have to go up to 13 which is a king
at this point you should be recognizing
these numbers they're very famous
mathematics numbers for at least 800
years 1 2 3 5 8 13 well the next one of
course would be 21 these are the
Fibonacci numbers and if you add 1 & 2
you get 3 if you add 2 & 3 you get 5 you
add 5 & 3 you get 8 you add five and
eight you get 13
you had 13 8 you get 21 it keeps going
but at that point you're beyond the
range of a deck of cards
so for the card shark you only go with
ace to 13 so I've chosen these
particular ace 2 3 5 8 and 13 and I've
memorized the suits I've been doing this
trick for a while so I put those at the
top and I shuffle and you're going to be
picking cards from those 2 and it turns
out that Fibonacci numbers have this
magic property that you will always be
able to decompose the thumb so I pretend
to shuffle and I do in fact mix these
cards up and I don't know which ones
you're going to pick so again let me
just show you - and you tell me what the
total is and I'll tell you immediately
what the cards are okay 14 so it's a
king and an ace now how did I know that
III would say of course in performance
but it could have been a 7 & a 7 it
could have been a 10 and a 4 but I don't
have sevens among the cards you're gonna
pick from there's no other possibilities
when you have six numbers there are 6
times 5 over 2 which i think is 15
different ways you can add them up in
pairs usually you get some collisions
like 1 plus 4 is the same as 2 plus 3
but with these Fibonacci numbers you
never get collisions you'll get 15
distinct numbers and secondly it's easy
to actually break up the numbers here's
the trick and try it again I'll just mix
them up here I'd ask you to tell me what
these two add up to what are those two
add up to 15 so here's what I'm doing in
my head 15 is the sum of two Fibonacci
numbers what's the biggest Fibonacci
number less than 15 I think it's 13 so
it's 13 plus well the subtraction is
easy is 13 plus 2 so it's the King and
the two and the suits
there's no mathematics info
I have to memorize the suits but I do
memorize the suits if you wanted to this
the first time an easy version just just
use the six values in question use all
diamonds it's always going to be two
diamonds if you do the trick once for
somebody to probably get away with it
it's a good way for a student to learn
to do the trick but for a more
sophisticated version that's a little
more convincing use different suits and
memorize them so I just again happen to
use the ace of clubs the two of hearts
the three of spades the five of diamonds
notice that suit order is c-h-s d called
the chased order and then you repeat the
cycle of the suits so of course it's
possible to get two of the same suit
with six cards that's unavoidable I
usually actually leave the ACE out of
the mix simply because if the total
three it's too obvious and three could
only be an ace than a two and then the
question of the suits isn't as
impressive but if you leave the ACE out
it's quite impressive if you've been
paying attention in the beginning you
might have noticed that I did in fact
use the smallest Fibonacci numbers 1 2 3
5 8 and 13 so that's the little fibs
trick and to be honest I did tell a few
little fibs or if not big whoppers
because I said I was shuffling the cards
so what we do is we take a deck of cards
and we shuffle the current I couldn't
possibly know what any of the cards are
those were little fibs it was a fake
shuffle I knew what cards you were
selecting your two cards from I didn't
know what they were
it wouldn't work with any 5 or 6 cards
you have to pick your numbers carefully
and the Fibonacci numbers work
beautifully for this trick so the little
fib was that you were serving the app
little fibs
I was dishing up some little fibs what
interestingly you can do other numbers
for instance you can start with a 2
first and then a 1 and then add those to
get 3 and add 1 and 3 to get 4 and add 3
and 4 to get 7